what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and as we get closer to
Avengers Secret Wars the MCU is indeed
going to start to connect a lot more
especially when we start phase five I
know some fans have been kind of
disappointed so far with the lack of
connectivity that phase four has had in
the MCU however it looks like things are
about to change and are about to get
very very exciting today we have a
report that some old actors are going to
be returning for Secret Wars
specifically Robert Downey Jr and at the
same time it looks like we have some
news about John Krasinski possibly
returning to play Mr Fantastic the main
Mr Fantastic of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe something that fans really
really want especially after seeing him
in Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness and his wife Emily Blunt could
possibly be coming along too to play The
Invisible Woman as some things that she
said before in the past are little bit
different than what she has to say about
the MCU now now there's a lot of really
exciting things about to happen in the
MCU but here's what is truly truly
exciting it looks like everything that
we basically wanted from Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness we are
actually going to be getting an Avengers
Secret Wars and this makes sense many
people thought that doctor strange and
the Multiverse of Madness was just going
to be filled with cameos and different
variants of different characters people
from the fox Universe people that
haven't been introduced to the MCU yet
and while we did get some of that with
John Krasinski as Mr Fantastic and
Patrick Stewart from the fox franchise
as Professor Xavier we really only got
these other variants in one other
Universe if we're not counting the other
doctor strange variants but Secret Wars
has the potential to be so much more and
it looks like it is going to be more as
we have a report today that Disney is
planning on getting back Robert Downey
Jr as Tony Stark slash Iron Man in
Avengers secret War now here's the
really really cool thing about this well
one is obviously that Robert Downey Jr
would return to the MCU this would be
fantastic to see of course he is an icon
of the MCU he started it all with Iron
Man and it would just simply be amazing
to see him in Avengers Secret Wars back
in the MCU I also should note that this
is backed up by The Insider account my
time to shine hello who has been
extremely accurate with her Scoops so
that's another very exciting thing but
two this opens up the door and this
means that Marvel Studios wants old
actors to come back to play variants of
their MCU selves which is fantastic news
because that means we could get people
like Chris Evans returning to play a
variant of Captain America we could have
the three Spider-Man together once again
or even more Spider-Man joining them and
this does open up the door for John
Krasinski to return in secret Wars
however there is still a big chance that
he could play the main mcu's Reed
Richards and we'll talk about that in
just a bit but first a big thank you to
to established titles for sponsoring
this video this one's actually really
cool and very personal to me because
I've actually used established titles
before my family is from Scotland and
they do a lot of great work for the
environment with established titles you
can officially become a lord or a lady
and when I say that I literally mean it
you can change your name to Lord or lady
and get it on your credit cards or plane
tickets and you get an official
certificate here's mine in Scotland if
you own a piece of land you are referred
to as Lord or lady through established
titles you get one square foot of land
in Scotland which officially makes you a
lord or a lady and you get a certificate
with your unique plot Number where you
can see the exact location of your land
and something truly great is they plant
a tree with every order and work with
global Charities once you're planted and
trees for the future to support Global
restoration efforts this makes a perfect
last minute gift for somebody and the
first 200 people purchasing a title pack
using my link will effectively be next
to my plot within a few minutes of
walking distance and and depending on
how many of you want to become a lord or
a lady we can build our little Cosmic
Wonder Kingdom and right now established
titles is running a massive sale plus if
you use the code Cosmic wonder you get
an additional 10 off so go to establish
titles.com Cosmic Wonder to get your
gifts now and help support the channel
so with Disney wanting Robert Downey Jr
to return this means that they most
likely want other members of the MCU who
are no longer in the MCU to return as
well this means that we are truly going
to get the movie that we thought we were
going to get in Multiverse of Madness
This truly means that secret Wars is
going to be the biggest Marvel Studios
film of all time not only are we going
to be getting old characters returning
like Robert Downey Jr most likely Chris
Evans and of course Black Widow but we
are also going to have all of the new
characters like the X-Men the Fantastic
Four but not just the X-Men and the
Fantastic Four from our universe we're
going to get them from other universes
as well but actually before we dive into
that let's talk about John Krasinski
still possibly being in the running to
play Mr Fantastic in our main Marvel
Cinematic Universe recently rumors have
been going around that a lot of other
people are being considered to play Mr
Fantastic Reed Richards of the MCU as
well as Sue storm however I don't
believe we should be ruling out John
Krasinski and his wife Emily Blunt to
play these two characters because I've
said this before in another video but
Marvel Studios might actually be
trolling us with all of these other
casting rumors that are going around but
more on that in a bit let's talk about
what Emily Blunt has recently said about
John Krasinski playing Mr Fantastic as
it turns out she has hopes that he is
going to return in an interview with hey
you guys at the London Film Festival she
was asked about her husband playing Mr
Fantastic in the MCU in Multiverse of
Madness and this is what she said I was
really happy for him because I think
he's a huge fan and I understand why
it's such an Ardent passionate religion
for people it's a huge part of our
cinematic history now so he was thrilled
the interviewer then said well I think
everyone else was as well hoping we can
see him again in which Emily Blunt said
yeah well I hope so I hope so you never
know and then she put her finger up to
her mouth as to go shh and keep a secret
when she said that which of course is
always very interesting now of course
either way this is a big tease whether
it's true or not Emily Blunt knows
exactly what she's doing when she puts
her finger to her mouth it could mean
nothing but it also could mean hey I
can't really say anything about this so
let's stop asking me questions now
what's really interesting here is that
it does seem like Emily Blunt's view of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has
changed over the past couple of years
over the past couple of years in random
interviews she has been asked about the
role of Sue storm because of course all
of the fans have been fan casting her
and her husband as Mr Fantastic and The
Invisible Woman and most of the time she
has said that she wouldn't want to play
that role basically stating that she
doesn't really have a passion for the
MCU and doesn't totally understand it
which is of course completely fine it's
not for everybody and that's okay
however her mind seems to have changed
and she now seemingly understands what
all the hype is about we see this as she
says and I understand why it's such an
Ardent passionate religion for people
it's a huge part of our cinematic
history now clearly here her views have
changed so could this mean that she
could possibly debut as The Invisible
Woman Sue storm in my personal opinion I
think this makes this entirely possible
now I believe that John Krasinski is
still in the running to play the main Mr
Fantastic of rmcu yes Kevin feige kind
of did it as fan service casting John
Krasinski and Multiverse of Madness
however well one we don't know the whole
story about that and two he was perfect
he was literally perfect as Mr Fantastic
and you can't ignore that and Kevin
feige definitely knows when somebody is
perfect for a role so it could be
possible that they weren't really going
considering him before however after
Multiverse of Madness they could be
considering him for the main Mr
Fantastic and I think they would be
fools to not at least consider that
possibility especially if you have his
wife willing to play Sue storm who of
course is the wife of Reed Richards in
Marvel history so this would be pretty
dang perfect but even if either aren't
cast for The Fantastic Four film they
could return in secret Wars because it
sounds like nothing is off the table if
they are indeed going to be bringing
back Robert Downey Jr in which it does
seem like they want to so I know
typically we should keep our
expectations low but considering the
fact that this is going to be an
Avengers film and it is Secret Wars I
believe that we are going to get a ton
of cameos people from the fox Universe
old X-Men even the old Fantastic Four
are on the table this is a movie where
incursions are going to happen and
universes are going to collide this is a
movie where literally anything is
possible and it sounds like we're
getting started off on the right foot
already with Marvel Studios 1 and Robert
Downey Jr to return as a variant of Iron
Man so this movie truly is going to be
huge but let us know what you think
about all of this in the comments down
below are you excited for Robert Downey
Jr's return if that does officially
happen and do you think John Krasinski
and Emily Blunt should play Reed
Richards and Sue storm in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe let us know your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news for
live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof